I always end up cooking like their big
holiday meals for my family like
Thanksgiving and Christmas it's like
always the one time of the year and I
spend like the entire day in the kitchen
so recently I was asked by Julie say to
make a homemade version of one of our
favorite foods
the McGriddle and email but today I'm
joined by Jake who's asking me to make a
homemade version of one of his favorite
foods animal style fries I'm actually
really excited for this one they're one
of my favorite foods too because they're
delicious
so delicious I actually love animal
style fries I've eaten a ton of them in
my 25 years I've never made them no so
I'm up for the challenge let's do it so
you know how do you know how to be a
student I think so this is I think the
onions in my favorite part about as
often as I eat and out which is on a
normal week twice a week for the last 20
years of my life what are we supposed to
taste like or be like but this
this I know
[Music]
which is actually a bit of a long
process so we should start on them the
number one ingredient is patience yes
something I need more good juicy looking
good yeah they're looking good so again
we just want to make sure onions are
like really super fine since they're
tiny so cook faster cuz they're tiny
right
the reason they take for a while is
because we have to cook them on a lower
heat and that will just make sure
they're sugars like caramelize
before they like really burn and that's
what makes them nice and like sweet so
now I'm just gonna put a tablespoon of
butter and our nuts
so what's your favorite part about the
animal style fries uh it's got to be the
onions but I mean it's a perfect mix of
everything to be animal self fries and
most all burger giver stuff to your
animal style fries inside your burger
sometimes Wow okay with our onions in
the pan so have you ever put fries in
the burger yes so actually that is my
that is my specialty but what I do is I
order a double-double and I get the
fries well done here I have gotten four
by four tons of times but I usually
prefer to get two double-doubles wow
I've never gone beyond a double all
right so now I'm just gonna season our
onions with a little bit of salt and now
we're just gonna wait for them to brown
and caramelize so if you wouldn't want
your onions you got it I'm just stirring
occasionally
I'm just gonna try to cut these pretty
uniformly so while you're finishing up
these onions which are looking and
smelling anyway I'm gonna start with our
Thousand Island dressing which is the
secret sauce that they add secret I
don't know if they add anything like
else
supposedly they do they might we're
gonna try to replicate it but I don't
know what the secret is
no wonder if there's like a round
probably love so I'm gonna put some
manis a couple of tablespoons of ketchup
great sound so now I'm gonna use this
sweet pickle relish which is key for
Thousand Island and we're gonna do a
little bit of sugar a little sweet but
it's also pretty tangy so we're adding
this distilled white vinegar fancy yeah
so I'm gonna mix this up and give it a
taste and see if it needs anything else
but you got to have that like nice like
pink color like the Thousand Island
dressing has no I love a saucy sake
yeah burger you know when they're animal
burgers actually girl they're mustard on
the buns too yeah I know okay you know
you can just have them grill mustard
without having an animal style to an end
that is special like a double-double
with mustard it tastes like we're going
for right there is something missing
though I do feel like there's something
missing but I don't know what maybe it's
love
all right the onions are done the sauce
is done now it's time to fry which is
probably the most dangerous part about
this yeah I tried following once in
college and it didn't end up well and I
haven't tried to fry anything at home
yeah it'll be okay though
I fry all the time and I haven't burn
anything down yet so our fries are ready
to dunk so don't worry you're in this
Boston
I know so we're gonna do a double fry so
I'm first frying these at 300 degrees
and that just is and that just means the
potatoes will have time to cook at a
lower - let me just grab it Oh God so
now we're gonna wait until our oil gets
too boring on degrees and we're gonna
plate the fries back in so they're
golden and crispy like this came again
we're almost there
and once they get there which will be
pretty fast oh yeah they're already
golden yeah we are gonna pop them in
just like they came from a restaurant
right hopefully they taste like it to
the best restaurant in the world and in
help okay I was super fast so now we're
draining the excess oil back on this
rack and I'm going to salt them
now so that we get all the salt on there
Wow
they're still hot and fresh cardboard
fish that is not homemade this is
actually from it in help but I hadn't
wanna make one so we're gonna pile these
up in here now we have our American
cheese which it's supposed to melt all
right and then of course we have our
delicious caramelized onion that's the
best part so I'm just gonna plop those
right on there you can kind of spread
them out nicely oh those look so good
great color on that take well what would
you have said it I don't know
and then our final ingredients the
homemade Thousand Island sauce the
secret sauce yes
you know it's hard to even like look
like in-and-out fries it look like like
I wouldn't doubt it except for we need
the cheese to melt a little more so now
I'm just gonna pop this in the oven so
the cheese melts and then we'll be ready
to eat so as far as taste goes in and
out is a little bit of a tricky one
because unlike most fast food they still
use pretty fresh ingredients so it's
hard to really improve upon that aspect
but I do think we may be able to beat
them on the fries I think you're right I
mean a lot of people don't like the
fries very much I'm not one of those
people want me to say that but a lot of
people don't so this might be better for
a lot of people let's see I guess we're
going to try these yeah start with in
and out yeah let's start with in and out
and have the base line let's remember
what we love so much I like where your
head's at I always want to get the like
the cheesiest sauciest bite right like
you talked to that's what's a little sad
is that what's at the bottom it's so bad
I need the top off
should we try ours move on over now the
real moment I'm a little nervous a lot
to live up to
please get nervous cuz I'm like I hope I
didn't disappoint
especially this one because I don't want
to disappoint you know well also it's a
really really high standards high bar
that's okay all right let's try do it
I'm really good I need to know right hey
I'm very tasty
the fries are better for sure yeah I
want an animal style my life I still
think I'm gonna go to in and out though
I'm never gonna stop yeah and I'm
probably not gonna make this home
because I can still buy it but this is
delicious
you did a good job well we did it never
doubted you but this still turned out
better than I expected
well thank you I'm so glad I could be of
service and now you can clean it all
[Music]
[Music]